[Musica]
[Applauso]
una delle mie passioni è notare in acque
libere e l'ho fatto anche qui ieri sera
nel vostro magnifico mare a ottobre mare
caldo 5 gradi più caldo della media
piacevolissimo naturalmente ma anche un
campanello d'allarme per il nostro
pianeta
il 2022 è stato l'album più arido e
caldo in Italia di sempre ed è stato
anche l'anno in cui la drammatica
situazione in Ucraina ci ricorda ogni
giorno quanto siamo vulnerabili alla
Geopolitica per il nostro accesso
all'energia
quello dell'energia è una problema
globale
Dobbiamo trovare una sorgente di energia
che sia pulita sicura
disponibile per tutti è compatibile con
lo sviluppo sostenibile ovvero che
permetta un benessere per tutti senza
mettere un ipoteca sul futuro del nostro
pianeta
Che cosa possiamo fare
Non c'è dubbio che nel futuro avremo una
grande parte del nostro fabbisogno che
sarà coperta dalle energie rinnovabili e
dobbiamo fare tutti in modo che la loro
efficienza venga aumentata quella dei
pannelli solari quella delle centrali
eoliche a vento
Ma è anche vero che le rinnovabili da
sole non ce la possono fare perché sono
intrinsecamente intermittenti non c'è
sempre il sole non c'è sempre vento ci
sono le stagioni giorno la notte le
nuvole
quindi l'energia che si producono deve
essere immagazzinata deve essere
stoccata da qualche parte e lo
stoccaggio dell'energia è un problema
molto dispendioso sia dal punto di vista
economico che da quello ambientale
c'è bisogno di un'energia di base che
aiuti che spalleggia le rinnovabili che
fornisca energia come dove e quando ne
abbiamo bisogno
quasi tutti i paesi hanno realizzato
questa necessità alcuni di fanno fronte
costruendo ancora
centrali basate sull'energia fossile sui
combustibili fossili
sappiamo che oggi usiamo più dell'80%
di combustibili sotto forma di
combustibili fossili
il sole Li ha prodotti
su decine di milioni di anni tramite i
suoi ragionamenti e tre metri per i
processi geologici sulla terra
noi ci testiamo letteralmente bruciando
su decine di anni
Quindi è chiaro che non possiamo
continuare a usarli finiranno ma appunto
l'urgenza di trovare alternative come le
rinnovabili viene non solo dalle
Geopolitica Ma naturalmente dal clima
questo bruciare che noi facciamo Non
fate produrre gas effetto serra quindi
contribuire al riscaldamento globale
Quindi questa idea dei paesi come la
Germania di costruire centrali a
combustibile fossile per aiutare le
rinnovabili forse non è proprio
completamente sostenibile altri paesi
come la Francia
per questa energia di base di cui
abbiamo bisogno usano l'energia nucleare
convenzionale la fissione
con i suoi pro e i suoi contro
ci sono altre possibilità abbiamo
alternative per avere energie che siano
disponibili per tutti e senza rischi per
il pianeta dobbiamo pensarci molto bene
dobbiamo pensarci prima che sia troppo
tardi allora pensarci prima mi viene in
mente
un personaggio studiato ai tempi lontani
del liceo colui che pensa prima
però meteo vi ricordate di Prometeo il
titano amico dell'umanità e del
Progresso che ruba il fuoco agli dei
perdava dagli uomini allora perché non
pensiamo come Prometeo Perché non
andiamo a rubare il fuoco agli dei per
portarlo sulla terra
cos'è il fuoco degli Dei
il sole le stelle
il sole è la nostra Stella e tutta
l'energia ci viene direttamente o
indirettamente dal sole
Cerca un centinaio di anni fa abbiamo
capito come funziona il sole come
funziona tutte le stelle funzionano
secondo il principio della fusione
nucleare
mettono insieme dei piccolissimi nuclei
delle piccolissime particelle per
formarli ancora nuclei relativamente
piccoli e rilasciare dell'energia
i nuclei
che formano questa reazione che è la
reazione di fusione all'inizio sono un
po' più pesanti si è persa della massa
quando alla fine hanno fornito la
reazione questa Massa che si è persa si
è trasformata in energia come dice
Einstein Massa energia sono la stessa
cosa sono equivalenti
a partire dall'idrogeno si forma l'elio
e via via tutti gli altri elementi e
così che funzionano le stelle ma anche
così che si è formato tutto l'universo
è il contrario dell'energia di fissione
l'energia nucleare convenzionale che si
basa solo spaccare dei nuclei grandi
complessi radioattivi
e tramite i processi di Reazione a
Catena spaccando ancora altri Sempre
complessi sempre radioattivi
Questa è della fusione è un'energia
pulita
non ha
scorie radioattive e l'energia sicura
perché non ha processi di Reazione a
catena di cui si potrebbe perdere il
controllo
e la densità di energia nel combustibile
È gigantesca tale per cui il
combustibile
che si trova in parte in natura in parte
lo forniamo noi stessi tramite i
prodotti delle relazioni nucleari e
praticamente illimitato
e voglio dare un esempio prendiamo la
mia città di origine Milano
un milione e mezzo di abitanti diciamo
due tre volte Genova uno stadio
magnifico allo stadio di San Siro voglio
alimentare la città di Milano per un
anno di energia
un anno Oggi giorno lo faccio con
combustibili fossili diciamo del carbone
per un anno all'energia per Milano
bisogna riempire Tutto lo stadio di San
Siro fino a terzo anello compreso 80.000
posti fino in cima di carbone immaginate
quanti tagli devono venire a Milano ogni
anno migliaia di treni carichi di
carbone per l'energia di un anno
ora
non dico se ma dico quando utilizzeremo
il combustibile di fusione nucleare non
avrò bisogno di treni non avrò bisogno
anche di un'automobile per portarlo avrò
bisogno semplicemente del rimorchio
della mia bicicletta
l'energia sarà custodita in una sacca
per un anno per un milione e mezzo di
persone
Voi direte fantastico ma perché non
l'abbiamo ancora cosa stiamo aspettando
ci stiamo arrivando
ci stiamo arrivando ma non è facile fare
una stella sulla terra bisogna prima di
tutto fare in modo che questi nuclei che
dicevo Si debbono fondere si avvicinano
abbastanza riunioni agli altri bisogna
fare riscontrare ad altissima velocità
velocità disordinata a livello
microscopico E chi dice velocità
disordinata microscopica dice alta
temperatura qui penserete centinaia di
gradi no vi sto parlando di decine
centinaia di milioni di gradi
può esistere la materia questo a questa
temperatura Sì può esistere ma non negli
Stati che abbiamo l'abitudini di
conoscere tutti i giorni sulla terra non
nello stato solido non nello stato
liquido neanche in quello gassoso Perché
tutte le molecole tutti gli attimi
sarebbero dissolti spaccati divisi fra
nuclei ed elettroni si crea una specie
di zuppa di particelle cariche che hanno
voglia di andare da tutte le parti che
si chiama il plasma il Quarto Stato
della materia
uno stato che ci sembra molto esotico e
lo è sulla terra ma in realtà tutto
l'universo praticamente tutto l'universo
a noi noto è in stato di Plasma e lo
sono in particolare le stelle di cui noi
vogliamo fare delle piccole copie sulla
terra per tirarne l'energia come moderni
promette quando e dove ne abbiamo
bisogno
Allora dobbiamo portare il plasma a
queste temperature di milioni decine
centinaia di milioni di gradi
come fare
pensiamo un po' le nostre cucine abbiamo
dei forni a microonde onde
elettromagnetiche potremmo usare quelle
Noi abbiamo bisogno di una piccolissima
quantità di materia
perché la densità di energia è enorme
quindi prendiamo una piccolissima
quantità di materia e una frazione di un
minuscolo cucchiaino di minestra
e lo iragiamo con l'equivalente di
migliaia di colonne di microonde Cosa
succede a questa piccolissima frazione
in un cucchiaino di minestra diventa più
calda del centro del Sole e dal luogo
delle reazioni di fusione lo facciamo
tutti i giorni nelle nostre esperimenti
però le stelle in particolare il sole
hanno un enorme vantaggio rispetto a noi
sono grandi
essere grandi vuol dire avere una grande
Massa quindi vuol dire tenere a sè
tenere insieme questo plasma che
scapperebbe da tutte le parti perché
forza per la forza di gravitazione noi
non possiamo permetterci di fare una
stella sulla terra che sia più grande
della terra della terra stessa dobbiamo
essere più furbi Però anche in questo
caso vediamo cosa fa la natura e godiamo
questa immagine c'è il sole col suo
plasma che scappa un po' da tutte le
parti anche se la gravità della cerca di
tenerlo insieme e poi c'è la terra che
sarebbe immersi in un mare di plasma che
ci brucerebbe in realtà la Terra è
protetta Ma di che cosa potete protetta
da uno scudo da una gabbia
che è quella fatta dal suo campo
magnetico Sapete che la Terra è un campo
magnetico Naturalmente con una Come
fosse una grande calamita Polo Nord polo
sud e questa gabbia tiene il plasma
l'esterno l'idea è
fare una gabbia ma metterci il plasma
dentro evitare che lui esca in modo che
lo possiamo tenere lì e farlo fondere
ovvero avere delle energie pulite la
gabbia che ha avuto più successo finora
si chiama tocca Ma che è un nome che
suona Russo ed è russo Infatti è stato
inventato Negli anni cinquanta del
secolo scorso in Russia adesso è un
un'idea che viene usata globalmente
Ed è proprio attraverso
una serie di tokamack di esperimenti e
grazie al fatto che a partire dal 1958
la
fusione è stata declassificata Ovvero la
si fa tutti insieme in collaborazione ed
in pace che abbiamo ottenuto una serie
di progressisti i risultati molto molto
importanti Alla fine degli anni 90
abbiamo ottenuto il record di potenza di
fusione sulla terra da una piccola
stella in un toccamac nel Regno Unito
vicino a Oxford
e dico a noi abbiamo perché eravamo
tutti noi europei insieme avevo la
fortuna di essere nella sala di
controllo e di operare l'esperimento
c'era la BBC c'erano i media locali che
registravano le nostre voci accenti
lingue di ogni tipo compreso
probabilmente la conversazione che avevo
immagino sul campionato di Serie A col
mio vicino ingegnere italiano
abbiamo
ulteriormente studiato questo problema
Abbiamo qualche mese fa battuto il
nostro stesso record l'abbiamo fatto in
condizioni ancora più vicini a quelle di
oratore e questo fatto di aver ottenuto
queste performance questi record non
convinto tutti noi del campo ma
soprattutto tutti i politici che ci
sostengono che ce la possiamo fare è
possibile costruire una stella sulla
terra
ma anche che dobbiamo farlo tutti
insieme e difatti il prossimo passo
è fatto da noi tutti insieme quando
dicono tutti insieme in questo caso non
dico solo noi europei ma dico
praticamente più di metà del mondo
l'Europa in questo caso ha 6 partner
la Russia la Stati Uniti d'America la
Cina la corea l'India il Giappone
e la Cina
si tratta del progetto IT Il progetto
che dimostrerà una volta per tutte la
fattibilità scientifica e tecnologica
della fusione sulla terra
produrrà 10 volte più potenza questo
piccolo plasma questa piccola stella di
quella che noi vi inietteremo
Questi sette partner lavorano insieme
non soltanto fornendo finanziamenti e
personale ma anche fonendo proprio i
componenti pezzi più di un milione di
pezzi nel puzzle più complicato mai
messo insieme dall'essere umano
facendo questo ognuno dei partner ognuno
degli Stati che partecipano avranno la
capacità la tecnologia di costruire il
loro proprio il retro fusione quando
funzionerà la fusione non sarà
un'energia soggetta ricatti di Unione di
uno Stato rispetto a un altro non sarà
soggetto a colonizzazione dell'energia
sarà per tutti è un progetto Infatti
nato come progetto di pace alla fine
della guerra fredda
discussioni fra la lega e Gorbaciov
però è ancora un esperimento scientifico
questo plasma questa piccola stella
tutti i sistemi che lo circondano
dobbiamo farli funzionare in maniera
affidabile
non soltanto per un esperimento
scientifico
abbiamo fatto funzionare per tanti anni
per decenni
per fare questo abbiamo ancora alcuni
sfide scientifiche tecnologiche da
affrontare e da vincere dobbiamo
controller ancora meglio questo plasma
che è scappata da tutte le parti i suoi
avvenimenti un pochino violenti quando
c'è una specie di eruzione dobbiamo fare
dei magneti ancora più efficienti
pensate che questi magneti sono
mantenuti praticamente allo Zero
Assoluto a qualche centimetro dal posto
più caldo dell'universo il posto più
freddo dell'universo ha qualche
centimetro dal posto più caldo
dell'universo e noi lo facciamo in
laboratorio
i materiali che contengono questa Stella
la bottiglia dentro la quale questa
Stella contenuta immaginate che devono
sottoporsi a carichi termici giganteschi
sotto L'unica cosa che mi viene in mente
come confronto è quello con un veicolo
spaziale che deve partire dalla terra e
andare nello spazio i suoi motori sono
sottoposti a dei carichi termici
giganteschi come quelli cui abbiamo
far fronte a noi nel reattore solo che
questo dura qualche decina di secondi
qualche minuto per il razzo per noi deve
durare decenni Ognuno di questi problemi
sta trovando una soluzione scientifica e
tecnologica e quello che resta da fare è
di metterli
tutti insieme ed è l'ultima tappa che ci
rimane prima di aver vinto la sfida
della fusione
per mettere tutti insieme noi stiamo già
lavorando al progetto che in parte in
parallelo agli etern in parte seguirà
Hitler che noi in Europa chiamiamo demo
per reattore di dimostrazione
demo
dimostrerà che è possibile far
funzionare la stella
non solo come esperimento scientifico
che è interessantissimo ma non interessa
la società per le applicazioni per far
funzionare citare gli ospedali ma come
centrale elettrica di produzione di
energia che produca molta più energia
elettrica di quella che consuma E lo
credo faccia in maniera affidabile per
decenni ed hanno un costo che sia
competitivo
l'orizzonte temporale di Demo visto da
noi europei e a metà di questo secolo
anche se io sono assolutamente convinto
che riusciremo ad accelerare perché
l'urgenza di avere una fonte di energia
pulita è enorme ed è percepita da tutti
e la nostra capacità di assorbire
innovazione intorno a noi è in continuo
miglioramento
sono tempi lunghi ma sono tempi
necessari e come costruire una
cattedrale è un processo che va da
generazione a generazione
transgenerazionale
mai come oggi però io sono convinto che
il sogno di realizzare una stella sulla
terra si avvererà
Peter è già quasi costruito
siamo già sulla buona strada per demo
il sogno si sta avverando
alla fine di questo percorso avremmo
vinto una sfida epocale una sfida
epocale per il futuro energetico del
nostro pianeta ma anche per il futuro di
tutti noi insieme
una sfida scientifica
tecnologica ma anche una sfida umana che
sarà stata affrontata e vinta perché
siamo stati capaci di farla insieme
in collaborazione
coesi ed in pace
non uno non 10 non 100 1000
promette I Moderni che lavorano per le
generazioni a venire e che hanno
adottato il motto Che nativi americani
ripetono sempre che cioè che noi non
abbiamo ereditato il nostro pianeta del
nostro antenati Noi l'abbiamo preso
prestito dei nostri figli
Grazie
[Applauso]